By 18-year-old son has consulted with you regarding the acne and is unagglutant and dairy-free diet,
he wondered if our homemade broth stock was a good thing to use for his bone strength, etc.
What would you suggest for an addition to his diet since he does not consume any dairy?
Okay, so remember, is dairy your number one source of calcium in minerals for your bones?
No, no. So a lot of people in our dairy-free diet are like, oh, what's going to happen with my bone
strength? This stock will be good. I'm not eating dairy. Thinking that that's what I'm getting
by minerals from some minerals that are in dairy, your body can't use, but not real effectively.
So I'm not knocking dairy, so first of all, if you're, I know this person who's asking this question,
I'm pretty sure isn't, but let's say you're talking about pasteurized dairy, there's much less
value in pasteurized dairy than in raw dairy, but let's say we're using raw dairy,
raw cheese, raw milk, we're getting from a farmer or from our old cow, then there's more value in that.
What do you pasteurize that you lose a lot of the value because you're losing all the enzymes that
are helping you absorb the minerals that are in dairy? So let me take a step back. Where do we get
most of our minerals from that bill bone that we use for coenzymes and cofactors in the enzymatic
activity and metabolic activity in our cells? Most of that is from our vegetables. Some is from
grass-fed beef too, grass-fed meat and raw dairy, but most is from your vegetables. So of course
that takes, okay, I'm not drinking milk, where am I going to get my calcium from my bones? First of all,
your bones need a lot more than just calcium-lating minerals. Second of all, the biggest source of
minerals for your bones and for your rest of your body is your vegetables. Third, you get that
also from eating grass-fed meats as well. So bone broth is at a good form of minerals. Well,
it turns out what you have in it if it's just, again, you remember, a cancer patient wouldn't be
drinking bone broth. It's got too much glutamate in it. I can feed cancer, but non-cancer patient,
you're making bone broth or you're making soups with, you're making it correctly, oh,
I think correctly, where you're taking chicken, put it in the pot and your boil it until meat falls
off and then you take the chicken out. Take all the meat off, cut it up and then you put all your
vegetable vegetables in there and you make your soup. But so you're getting some of the bone nutrients
out of the bones of the animal as well. So you can do that making bone broth as well. You're cooking
bones on beef bones or chicken bones or whatever bones you're cooking and cooking them for a long
period of time to get the nutrients out of the bone. Well, the negative about cancer is you're getting
a lot of glutamate in it in that which can feed cancer. So cancer patients wouldn't want to necessarily
do that, but it can be really good for healing skin and healing your gut and for patients who are
autoimmune. It's part of what's called the gap diet is using bone broth and brothy soups and
things like that to help heal the gut and to help heal the skin. So yes, bone broth and
bone stock is excellent for anybody with autoimmune issues, anybody with gut issues, anybody with
skin issues. And you get minerals from it too, yes, but it's really the other healing products of it that
are even exceed that. So yes, he can get his nutrient, a lot of nutrients from broth and soups and
things like that.